the FDA is holding a hearing this
morning to address the alarming spike in
teen vaping and how to help those who
want to kick the habit according to the
National Youth tobacco survey more than
20% of high school students admitted to
using an electronic cigarette within the
last 30 days that's an increase of more
than 77 percent since 2017 david beg no
is here to share a warning from parents
and students
David Goodwin John good morning vaping
has exploded in popularity the two young
people you're about to hear from have
both faked and now they're aiming to
limit access for others their age and
you know kids don't have to go to a
store to buy what they need to vape a
lot of them get it online it's just so
easy to get and it's just everywhere
fifteen-year-old Philip Furman and
seventeen year old Caleb Mints say
they're constantly surrounded by vaping
at school and out it's not really even a
social thing anymore people are just
doing it alone and it's just to get by
both of them have experience vaping
Philips since the eighth grade now they
are working to prevent their peers from
getting addicted we know as parents that
every day that goes by this epidemic
gets worse their mothers
Meredith Berkman and Dorian Furman are
cofounders of the group parents against
vaping East cigarettes or pave kids
don't understand really what is in a
vapor Jul they could be right according
to a survey conducted last year by the
truth initiative 63 percent of jewell
users aged 15 to 24 don't know that the
product always contains nicotine in the
beginning I actually thought Jul was
harmless and just consisted of water
vapor it's very addictive and it's
specially addictive for young people
linda richter is the director of policy
research and analysis at new york's
Center on addiction they are made of
type of nicotine that actually gets
absorbed into the bloodstream and
therefore to the brain quite quickly and
has its effects rapidly and quite potent
Lee a recent study found that
e-cigarettes could be a gateway to other
harmful products young adults who use
them are about four times as likely to
begin smoking cigarettes within 18
months
compared to those who don't physicians
who want to treat young people with
nicotine addictions also face a lack of
treatment options nicotine patches and
gums are not approved for children so
people turn to counseling to the extent
that that works great but there's really
no good studies or evidence out there
right now about exactly what types of
counseling would work best the largest
East cigarette company jool labs says it
has taken some steps to limit exposure
to children last November the company
shut down its Facebook and Instagram
accounts it also cut off its supply of
certain flavored pods to more than
ninety thousand retailers that will not
necessarily stop kids like Phillip he
bought his first jewel pod on eBay if
you really try hard enough you'll be
able to find a jewel of faith within ten
seconds today the boys and their mothers
are going to Capitol Hill they will ask
the FDA to take all flavors of
e-cigarettes off the market they have
the authority to do it and we know they
want to protect our kids and this is the
way to do it but it has to be done
yesterday or younger kids will start
jewel controls about 70% of the
e-cigarette market in a statement the
company told CBS News underage use of
jewell and any other vaping products is
completely unacceptable and we will be a
transparent engaged and committed
partner with the FDA in the effort to
combat underage use one argument that is
expected to be heard in today's hearing
is this one vape pod has about the same
amount of nicotine as an entire pack of
cigarettes what a dictate what a nice
way to end that piece to really put a
button on it